die ms europa 2 ist mit 1864 von 2000
möglichen punkten das weltbeste
kreuzfahrtschiff bei uns sportlern kommt
auf die kleingärtner die gäste
wahrnehmen sehen und merken was wünschen
sich die gäste ohne dass sie selber
sagen müssen
da gibt es kein nein vom service her
sind wir so gut vom vom level er
bestückt dass wir auch individuellen
service und gast lassen kulinarisch wird
an bord der ms europa für jeden
geschmack etwas geboten um alle
restaurants bedienen zu können arbeiten
der küche auf deck 3 insgesamt 56 köche
und 14 küchenhelfer also wir bieten
etwas an was die gäste nicht jeden tag
an land haben aber haben könnten
[Musik]